Well. Well, well go to your mom's house,
Christina,
your mom's house podcast.
Come for the moose soup.
Stay for Christina's sour dry personality.
There you go. That was very
rude. Uh, welcome. Created that.
That is Jake Glazer. He's a
voiceover artist. Certainly is.
I have a few. I have a great
bunch of submissions of his good.
They're good. Well, he's
outstandingly talented,
but I'm not sure I approve of the message.
Why not?
It's a bunch of has coming in here.
You're going to be impressed by it.
I'll give you, I'll give you
a taste of one more. Okay.
Your mom's house podcast with a black
people yell louder and the White People
fart harder. Oh, I like that. Yeah.
What an astute observation
too. It's funny, I never
would have like written that,
but you know. Hmm. Well there
you go. Pretty funny. Yeah,
the whites do for it harder
here. They do. Hey, speaking of,
did you hear my fart last night
at two in the morning? No, Bay by,
I didn't know it was asleep.
Two o'clock. No warning.
I know you didn't hear the baby crying.
It's weird how men don't seem to hear, uh,
infant crying,
but
maybe was howling and I went down there,
I came back and I let
out such a huge fart.
And it was really hoping to wake you
up at that point. Well, did I? No,
of course not. I'm not that I can
tell. I don't just ignore that cries.
I honestly don't hear the farts either.
So,
and I thought I had to shit last
night at two in the morning, which I,
that's your move. Yeah. That is my move.
It's also a good story because
this morning I woke up to,
you know, last night I thought I was
going to shit at two in the morning,
but I didn't. It was like, okay,
why do you want me to hold my stories
from you? I thought were married.
That's the whole point is that we share.
No, you're right. We are. We're worried.
We're two mommies. One gene. Yeah. I
don't forget. We're definitely one thing.
Yeah, that's what, that's
why we share a pair. Yeah,
absolutely. Wait, so how's our,
how's our dogs?
Our dog's butt hole. Yeah. The others,
they're running the test that they,
that they run for for itchy
butt holes. Is that right? Yeah,
they do a urine analysis because they,
they,
they think that it could be that her
badge is bothered and it looks like it's
her butthole. Okay. So they're doing that.
They have a fecal sample now they test
for like parasites and see if that's
what's what's bugging it.
And then they already did the actual anal
expression in the exam to see if there
was something that stood out. They
ask you to lick it and taste it. Yeah,
they said a funny, that
vet goes, I also to examine
you at the same time. And I was
like, that's weird why? He goes,
well a lot of times the owner and the pad,
it's like super advanced theory,
but they could be, you
know, mimicking each other.
And I said that's above my pay
grade, so go for it man. So he did,
he that he fingered me.
He expressed your anal glands.
So how'd that feel?
Felt great. Felt great.
Was it now the vet that you saw today,
was it,
was it the Zim zero one or was
it the no, no, no, it was a dude.
Are you presuming or straight up
why? I'm presuming, but it is, yeah,
he identified as male. Yeah.
I think I know. Is he like,
yeah, Kinda Kinda sloppy,
goofy kind of sweet guy. Yeah. I
guess is he crazy about Brussels?
Griffon I mean he,
he,
he didn't specify that and
he was definitely really
sweet with her. What Betsy?
Yeah. Yeah. Cause I,
when I brought her in there to get her
anal glands expressed about a month ago,
there was like a sloppy, floppy,
endearing that he was really into her.
He's like, oh my God, I
never see the Brussels. I'm
like, I know they're special.
Rare like me, my personality.
Hello. Hello? Hello? Um,
did he tell you what she was thinking?
No, that is my pet peeve though. Hell,
that is one of my,
like my ultimate pet peeves.
I can't believe I haven't taken it on
stage yet. I need to, I think I'm gonna,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna shoot this special in a few
weeks and then my next hour is going to be
called what your dog is thinking
or what she's thinking. What do you
think Betsy is thinking? Well, you know,
um,
your dog is feeling a little sad,
a little anxious, but
also hopeful. Uh, Ben,
this is something we've observed in
dogs for years. I was like hopeful.
And then did your dog, did the dog
report that to you when it did the uh,
the list, the check off list? Well
she's a Gemini. Did she tell you that?
The birth month, but yeah, so
dancer leaning, uh, you know,
it was great about Fifo.
So you took bitsy separately to the vet
and fefe was left behind and I thought
for sure fief would be like really upset.
You know,
why does busy didn't give a shit
was like, oh you're gone. Great.
And just that surprise,
he didn't feel a lick of anxiety.
Usually he's got major anxiety.
Yeah, he's such a mental case.
Fifo but didn't give one shit the busy,
it was
just pulled that one.
Cause I really,
I think that's my favorite part of the
whole thing. I think so. I think it's,
you guys are doing good and she says
it twice. It's grammatically incorrect.
Yeah.
Well I believe is the relative.
It makes me crazy. She's
really integrate. Yeah.
There's,
there's all kinds of great stuff
when she goes dirty bitch. Yeah.
Is that what she says? Dirty. Dirty. Yes.
That's weird. Oh yeah.
And
Gee,
you guys are doing good.
Yeah, she's awesome. Don't forget
your moose soup shirts are now
are,
well, the shirt actually have
a big announcement start.
You don't normally do this,
but I'll save it for during the show.
Let's get this show started
normally and then we,
I guess shitty later. All right,
let's start our show. Let's go here.
Oh, and g, welcome to another
episode of Your Mom's house.
Here we go.
Hi Melanie. Stadio carts. Tantra.
I was just wanting to share that
there are many ways to orgasm.
You don't actually have to be
having sex orgasm just from hugging.
Ah, ah. Ah,
okay.
How old is Ryan?
Don't bring anyone loving.
Well,
we'll go to your mom's house.
Christina. Pledges. It's interesting.
You guys are doing good.
You love him. She's your, your
first grade teacher. Oh my God.
Can I tell you how much I hate anybody
that engages in any form of Tantra?
Oh my God,
this shit really gets under my skin.
I hate how happy they are.
I hate how expressive they're
fucking misguided faces. Look,
uh, and I, I really
hated the fucking orgasm.
It was so stupid. There wasn't an
orgasm. Faker shaking. And he's like,
oh my God, that hug. Fuck you man.
Fuck You X. Right? Yeah.
Why? I feel like I hated it.
And look by that they
look like tantra practice.
That's the thing is that there's
always, oh look, yeah. Doing that thing.
Like it's so sensual.
That's the new I like.
I like, I like fucking,
I think, what are you doing? You're
putting your tongue over your teeth.
That's like the Maria Omg Maria phase.
That's like,
I feel like that's the
version now of like a, like a
mouth, a little open. It's
always the same dough. I,
you know, pie to kind of dopey.
Like they just need something.
That was like eight years, something like
that. Yeah. He's a rapper. He's right.
Who Do you think introduced hurts?
Is US amazing now.
Well that's a thank come when you
hug. These are, these are lost souls.
People who haven't found Christ,
but they find the tantric horse shit.
You know what I mean?
Like they're one seminar away from giving
20% of their income to Scientology.
Like they're just, they're right. If they
just took a different door, you know,
but they're, they're
finding tantra. Tantra,
I guess is the contrast.
People who sign up for come hugging
don't get what they signed up for.
I bet most people are like, I dunno, I
keep hugging but I'm still not coming.
And then they're like, he's
just, he's got to let it go more.
And then it's basically like speaking
in tongues in these, you know,
Pentecostal churches or it's like, how'd
that happen? And they're like, well,
that guy's kind of throwing
a little extra spice on that.
There's a little hot sauce on there
that you might not know about.
And it's called faking it. Schizophrenia.
Yeah. You got to buy in to the Koolaid,
you have to drink it all.
Get on board.
Especially when you start
to see everything can be
touching your body all over eating.
All I do is come on this woman all day,
every day.
Do you think they have small children
at home? These types? No. Look,
I know these people have nothing
in their lives then hold them down.
You have so much free time. How much
free time to be able to engage in Tantra?
Nothing but time. Yeah. Yeah.
Ah,
but do you think he's really nutting
and his shorts? No, of course. Sure.
Is it a dry rub? Like the Rub
Rub guy? Well that's, that
is there. That would help.
But I don't think that's what's happening.
But he says you can have an orgasm inside
the rub rub. Well, I've got, yeah, he,
you can and I don't, I
don't doubt that, but
I don't doubt that. But Rob,
Rob,
rob,
you know what's the problem with
all this stuff is, you know what?
I am happy when people find happiness in,
in horse shit like this. Yeah. But if
they're paying money to go to a seminar,
100% and it's like a thousand dollars
a day to learn how to come hug. Yeah.
It's like,
oh fuck.
Don't stop taking advantage of these
poor souls who just need Jesus.
That's how they make their money.
Taking advantage of hate it.
It'd be great to come when I hug.
If only there were a seminar, I could
pay $1,000 I'm all alone when I come.
I could come in public on it.
I probably my day way better.
I mean honestly,
I was thinking about that too.
That would be great if I'd be like,
you mean I can just start giving hugs?
Towns are coming. Yeah, that'd be great.
But of course there's the part of my
brain that goes, oh, that's not happening.
You're not going to do
that. Of course. Well,
and also don't you
think it's really messy?
You could have come in your pants all day.
Oh yeah.
It's not.
That happens every time you hug,
you can out of your mom. Aww.
How your mom, your dad like
that. Okay. Okay. Well,
what if that's the gift is that you
can come hug, but it's everybody.
It's indiscriminate. Come hugging. So you
hug your mother. Hello. You're coming.
You're dad, you're coming. Now you
can also hug. You know Josh Potter.
You're retarded.
I'd rather be retarded.
I think his phrasing is just,
I go retarded. Get amazing.
I ride. Okay, but, but listen,
you like the feature of the come hug,
but it has to be indiscriminate.
That's a thing. That's a problem.
That's a real problem. Yeah.
It's why I'm going to keep not coming
when I hug because I do want it to be
descriptive. But you like the
come hug is what I'm saying.
I do like the concept of a comma,
right? Yeah. So would you rather
have the chem hug but it's indiscriminate?
Yeah. Whoever, whatever. Uh,
all my friends like,
come on Ryan. I come on.
Are you full charge Joe? Yeah. All of
them. How are we talking about hugging my,
come on. Yeah. You say hi
to alley the comedy store
or be retarded. I mean,
it's a real simple,
I go retarded.
I'd be retarded for sure.
What would you do?
Oh,
well a woman's orgasm is a little more
discreet and I won't have a load in my
pants. Yeah, but you'd have,
I don't see my role to do that
thing where people would be like,
what's you'd have to deal with? Every
time we go on, like, what's going on?
You have to be like,
can we second?
You have to finish coming as they go.
Like, oh no, your hands would go like,
all right, all right in the hands,
kind of back off of you. Then you go,
so, um, good to see you. And then
they're going to like, I dunno. Cause,
and everybody would feel
like they'd be like,
it's a little presumptuous to
think she just came in my arms,
but they would think wrong with you.
Right.
But I could lie and tell them that I'm
having seizures and it's induced by
touch. It's a touch seizure.
They won't, nobody will know.
Now here's the one problem, because
I don't seem family. Who Cares?
My Mom's dead on the, her hug her,
but hugging my son does the problem.
Oh yeah. That'll, that's a lifetime of
calm hugs with our boy. I can't do that.
That's not cool. That's true. That's
the one reason I choose retarded.
Just for that. Yeah. Otherwise I would
come hug. I don't care. God Damn.
I just want to hug people as much, I
guess. Yeah, I guess so, right? Yeah.
Hey, can you move my camera up a little?
Can I move your camera up a little?
I feel like my, the top of my heads
being cut off. Oh, it moved? Yeah,
I didn't do that. When does
that happen? I have no idea.
Yeah, right. Yeah. Cause my head
looks like it's being cut off.
It's odd. I didn't touch that camera and
maybe accidentally it was moved. Bumped.
Hello? Yeah, right. Yeah.
O and g
it doing good.
You done real good?
Uh
Oh yeah. Oh, it's way better.
God, that was weird. No,
O m g clue. Oh, that one.
I moved for that Steve Pro.
So make sure that that's
framed right. O n. G
no, that's about right. That's cool. Yeah.
Okay. I want to get your moose
suit. It's really weird, man.
I mean, unless I was was in here
and now we're back. Now we're here.
All right. You guys are doing good. Okay.
Aren't you glad?
I mean,
of all the stations in life to be
born into that, that that wasn't your,
your mom, you know. Oh my
God, that's such a crap shoot.
It's such a crapshoot who,
who you're born to and where
I want to think about that.
When I think about how blessed I am that
I was born in like I was in what was,
you know, close enough to
America. Yeah. It could have been,
it could have been fucking really nuts.
But you would also think that
that's normal for a long time. No,
I was reading something on the Internet
about people in Hong Kong who live in
coffin apartments. Have you seen this
shit? No. It's like, it's like, you know,
people that drive cabs are our security
guards and can't afford the cost of
living in Hong Kong.
Yeah.
They pay something like $300 a month
and they live in what are basically like
125 square feet. Coffins. It's terrible.
And their TV there, you know,
toilet, their kitchen sink,
everything is in one narrow
rectangle and they sleep in it.
They do everything so horrible. And
then you start thinking yourself. Yeah,
but why don't you just live
somewhere else? Why worry?
Why don't you move to not Hong Kong and
go live where there's more space and
cost of living's cheaper. Dude, people
just love those. You know what the,
that's the same thing that people do in a,
and I feel like in New York especially.
Yeah, that's true. It's just like they go,
I don't care. I will live.
I will pay to live here.
I don't care what's inside of this.
Yeah.
Well the hope being that
you'll improve your, you know,
your income level and you'll eventually
not have four roommates or the whole
thing for you is that the value is based
on living in, in that area. It is. Yeah.
Again, but you're, you're in
New York City. Well that's
true. Maybe in Hong Kong.
It's the same here. Like I'm going to
move on up like the fucking Jefferson.
So this is, um, from the description
on this video, by the way,
we were watching a study revealed that
one in three women have trouble reaching
orgasm during sex,
or the research reveal that eight out of
10 women fake it meet the lucky couple
who have an orgasm from hugging husband
and wife can orgasm through anything
from lovemaking, breathing, dancing to the
weather conditions. They're from Texas.
They have full body orgasms
that lasts as long as 18 hours.
They're so connected.
If one of them has an orgasm in
the same room without touching,
the other automatically does as well.
Okay.
And the married couple of eight years
believes that anyone can learn to do this
thing. Okay. All right.
Has there been scientific tests? So, no,
I live in like experiments verifying
these bands. I don't think so.
I think there's, this is a lot of
acting lice. Yeah. Lies acting.
It's just like the gays. Yeah. I
wish you and I were that connected.
Why don't we have no, I'm good. That's
too much connection. Todd. Todd Tra?
Or is it Tantra?
Tantra.
Tantra is how much is it Taro
readings or Taro? Great question.
Well, I listened to these, you know,
nut bags on Hay House radio sometimes
and they have people that talk to angels
and people that talk to dogs and
stab pet psychics. I love it.
And sometimes they do say it that way.
They're like,
the Taro is calling your name $5
a minute and you're like, okay,
I know it's not true.
A,
by the way, born George [inaudible]
I have to say thank you Mel.
C Two Montreal.
I was in Montreal this week.
Did you have poutines I had a little
bite or two. Yeah, I should. It's delish.
Did you have a waffle? Like I told
you too, I did not have a waffle. Huh?
But I had, um, no, I had delicious food.
I had a great, great show at Olympia.
And then I also went to a Hampton Beach,
which the fun thing about a tour like
this where I've gone extensively touring
to so many places is hitting cities where
you're like, you have no expectations.
You have low expectations because you're
like, I've never even heard of this.
I was so confused by Hampton Beach,
New Hampshire. I thought I was going to
Hamptons. That's what I would have
thought. Yeah. All I know is not la.
I know.
That's what you think.
I still don't wear show was crazy there
then Wilmington Delaware had no, I know.
Or Delaware has no idea where the original
colonies didn't have a clue where it
was. I mean, I knew was
the northeast, that was all
I knew. Yeah, I've heard of it. And
then balls and whores, Maryland. Yeah.
Went fucking off man.
Just so you know, uh,
I mean if you were at that show in my
estimation for just as far as like fun and
reaction from the crowd, that had
to be a top five show on this tour.
That's awesome. And Ryan was there, sickle
cell went up there. He did his thing.
Josh Potter. Yeah. They, um,
that yet. They were great.
They were fantastic. But the crowd
was so fucking hyped, you know?
And that's honestly,
that's all comics are ever looking for.
Like when they get time, I loved it. And
you're like, why did you love that show?
Because the, the fucking show was great.
Yeah, because the crowd was great. Yeah.
They're on board. They get it. There's
no judgment. There's no, you know,
booing moment.
You know what it's like from the moment
you walk out, you know? Yeah. Yeah. If an,
if, if two seconds in you're like, Oh
God, this is going to be crazy. I know.
It was like that. So anyways, thank
God. What a blessing in the skies. Nice.
Yeah,
because sometimes like I don't,
I mean I can't look at this
tour and be like, that show was,
well actually there's a couple
of hours like oof. And I don't,
I feel like they didn't know how bad
I thought the show was, which is good.
You don't want to tell him
that this was terrible. Yeah.
But there was a couple where I was like,
Jesus,
but there's some that were
really fucking crazy. Yeah.
Like there was Montclair,
New Jersey.
I never thought I'd never heard of that
place. I didn't think that would I,
that was another one where I was like,
I've never even heard of this place.
And that is your jam jam in Seattle,
which I've heard of and I think it
towns, those shows were fucking
dare always jamming on the one.
They were pretty crazy. Always
jamming on the one I got really lucky.
Chicago always jamming
on the one. Yeah. Uh,
am I special taping that first cry was
fucking bananas. What a what a luck.
I'm watching because I'm editing
it all now and you're like big.
Those fuckers stood up the
minute I got out there.
Like they gave me a standing ovation.
Went just standing there. It was crazy.
It was so lucky. What if, what
a fortune fortuitous event,
if that's the right word. I don't know.
You know, it never goes down like that.
Stand up. You get a show like
that once every, that's what I'm,
that's what I'm saying, right? Like, and
when you have one of those at a taping.
Yeah. Like come on, you're
fucking like, oh my God.
Lightening in a mother
fucking tantric bottle. Yup.
You just want to keep getting coming
all you want to do it again and come man,
can I tell you what our toddler son
did today? Yeah. Quick rundown. Yeah.
So this morning,
uh,
you were running around doing stuff
and I was taking care of our son by
ourselves because our nanny,
our beloved amazed nanny's visiting
relatives in Guatemala. So we,
our nanny less. It's just
the two of us. Real people.
How can we survive? Oh, working
stiffs and uh, I mean, look,
we're up at the crack of six. Yeah, we're
at the playground. I'm chasing this kid.
He runs off into fields. We come home. Uh,
he's flipped over the dog water bowl.
There's water everywhere.
He sloshing around dog water hands. He
takes at any strips down. He's in his die,
die, rips his diet for off,
pisses in the playroom.
Just pisses on one of his toys like that
walker toy, like he's hiding behind it.
And then all of a sudden I see all
this water. I'm like, are you peeing?
And they did. And then he
does it again. Come back.
And they like 10 minutes later he's
like pulling down that died, died.
Pisses right on the tiles. Like he wants
to Piss into something, right? Yeah,
he does.
So I think that's what the sign is.
So I showed him the toilet and
I explained to him like, Hey,
you need to tell her
one more fucking time.
I will crack your fucking jaw if you
ever yeah. You do that or no? Yeah.
And your penis isn't dirty and
wrong. Yup. It's disgusting rule.
That's how I've heard to do it. You
telling me do this one more fucking time?
You're going to catch the back of my
hand. Yup. Yup. You know my Nana, uh,
in Hungary,
my Hungarian Nana used to
time my uncle to the toilet.
Like tie him with a rope to toilet,
train him. Do you think that's cool?
No.
He might have bathroom issues today.
She also dressed him up like a
girl until he was five. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm sure he's fine. They were
really good at child development.
It sounds like in the old world.
Yeah. Can, isn't that nuts. So that,
that's kind of what that is.
What they assume,
like you're born with an adult brain in
a baby body. Yeah. It doesn't make like,
how can they even assume that?
And I think that for the most part it
seems like every generation does way
better. Right then the last
one, well, theoretically, yeah,
but like our parents generation
there was good and bad in it,
but they're way better than
the generation. My Nana,
who's a total barbarian,
my dad said that
he had a pretty, like they had a good
relationship, you know, the parents,
but it was also like pretty formal.
Hmm. You know, it was like, you know,
he said like they would, if they would
show affection, but he would also,
I think he would say
like, yes sir. And um,
he said one time in college it
was, you know, there's senior week,
so seniors go to a beach
town, let's say, to,
to celebrate essentially that
they're going to graduate.
He wanted to go as junior year and
he said, I want to go to, I dunno,
whatever beach it was, Wilmington beach
to sell, you know, for senior week.
And His dad said,
I wish you wouldn't do that.
And that was the end of the company.
Big Fight, Huh? Well, he said
like argument. There was no
such thing as being like,
what the Fuck Dad? Of course it was
just understood that that means no, no.
That's how he just was like,
okay, you respect your elders.
Children should be seen and not heard,
which I mean the formality you see now
in top dog because his idea of lounge
wear his khakis on a Sunday
and loafers like he doesn't,
he has zero chill button. Yeah. Isn't
that wild? Yeah. That is chill for him.
He thinks that's super chill. Yeah.
Khakis, loafers, belt. What'd you wear?
Some comfortable button. Damn
comfortable. I am comfortable.
It blows me away every time when he's
over at the house on a Sunday and you're
like, dude, even at home at his own
house, he would wear that a button down,
tucked in Khakis and you're like,
why don't you want to wear sweat
pants or something? You know?
Like something real loud. I
like that. That's so weird.
Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. Like it. Our kiddos
on full tilt, but he was laughing.
That's what they're supposed to do,
right. They're supposed to be a little,
you know, naughty puppy. That's the point.
Yeah. He's having a blast. Yeah. He's,
he's doing when he's supposed to be
doing it just makes, makes a mess.
Our kitchen is a fucking
your mom's house park.
What's that? A fart.
Who did you just come and your grandpa's
old trusty hands time for some funnel
cake.
Yeah.
That's amazing. It's great.
It's good. That was so good.
Yeah. God, I really dazzled by that.
Welcome to your mom's house
podcast with your host,
the really fun engaging and we'll
hydrated Tom Segura and the full ticket.
Not as fun,
Christina.
There you go. That's not cool.
That is cool. It's not nice. Yeah.
The full Ted it. Yeah, they do get
bigger every year. How's that possible?
I don't know.
They're so big though.
Hey Mommy, can I get a grande?
A Vanilla Latte? Thanks gene.
Very good. Thanks. Jeans.
He did a pretty mommy.
Just glasses.
Hello? Yeah. Yeah, he did.
Um, a Rogan style. Oh,
hello.
Moose soup drinkers.
You know that that's like, yeah, cause
he does it. Yeah. Monkey thing and goes,
hello freak bitches. Oh yeah, yeah.
Tell us. Yeah. No, he didn't move super.
That's hilarious. Yeah. Um, yeah.
All Day. All night. Mom's house
podcast with Todd and Christina.
They got moose suit and everything.
Okay,
good Stinger. Here's this one.
This one's one of my favorites.
Your mom's house podcast.
Do you mind sleeve you
wishing you were retarded
magic. That was good. Jake. Thanks
very much. Drink laser. Thank you Jake.
That was great. Oh, nice nose picking.
Jesus. Our Son has picked it out to, okay,
what am I supposed to do
that it's so aggressive, Ben.
There's a lot of stuff on there.
I got to get it out.
You know how you enjoy your body functions
like you're the only person I know
that's like, oh don't you love a
good sneeze? Like, no, not really.
Like you really relish your
body functions like, oh,
I just took the best p or I just like
the biggest shit or I just, I don't,
the only thing I really, excuse
me, like I like taking a dump,
but that's more about relieving discomfort
for me. I don't really enjoy it. Yeah.
But I like picking my nose. Like
that's my one thing and I'm like, oh,
I love everybody picks. You know
everybody picks. They do. Everybody picks.
Yeah, I think so. I think everyone's
lying that says that they're not,
who doesn't pick their nose at some
point they might do it discretely.
They might do it really privately, but no
one doesn't clean their nose out. Yeah,
half deal. You have to of course. Yeah.
You're a little more of a savage about it.
I am. You know, at one
point my stepsister,
we were driving around and she was like,
stop picking your nose when we
were like 17 she's like, she goes,
this is too much, too much picking.
I'm like, I can't stop it. I know you.
I've seen you at the times where I'm
like, fuck man, that's, that's a lot.
I know it is, but I
enjoy myself. Welcome to
mom's house podcast.
Your favorite place to see Tom Segura
laugh at a man getting his legs crossed by
a moving vehicle.
Speaking of that, there's a this,
have you seen this one? This came in.
This is a video someone submitted.
Oh,
hi.
Did you call from the hospital?
Yeah.
I don't know, but she's screaming
really loud at the beginning.
She's in a hospital again on a moped with,
I don't know if that's a
neck brace on or something.
Oh,
Groucho phase
Facebook.
They're being
so nice to her
that Amy severe.
My Dad
does.
She screams as she does.
Not sound like Amy said.
Doris does like a character she would
do, right? Yeah. Yeah. That's amazing.
The world is so fucked up,
man.
No,
I'm telling you,
and I know this because now that I go to
the playground and I see other parents
with their kids, then you go, oh,
that's why you chase is everything.
You guys are fucking idiots and you're
raising idiots and there's more fucking
idiots and everybody's all worried about,
you know which kindergarten you send
your kid to and which preschool to get a
leg up. It doesn't matter because
most of people are are retards. Yeah.
Most of the world is full of idiots.
There's a
lot of stuff gets out there. Yeah. Would,
if you're a decent human, you're above.
You don't need to send them to a fucking
Montessori school.
So do you find it funny when she's
screaming like that or no, I'm more,
it makes me sad for humanity.
Like I don't, I don't,
I get real bummed out when she's
screaming like that. Yes. Why?
Because she should know better.
Like I get upset with humanity
because you shouldn't have,
she shouldn't be on her
mo. Yeah. Clearly. Clearly
hospitals.
But I like her screen really.
It was pretty fun. Yeah, it
is pretty funny. Yeah. No,
I like it. Yeah. Ah, yeah. That's great.
I'm really got a bad dates.
Gotcha.
That's a good scream. We're
damned. That's a good screen.
Okay.
And you know, she's just doing it for
attention. You think so? Yeah. I mean,
yeah.
Um,
here's the email we got. Can
you spit on tp? Is it okay to,
to spit on toilet paper
then wipe your be whole? No,
I am in the Denver airport bathroom
waiting for your response. Are you,
are you still there now wait,
waiting. Uh, I'm 100% yes on that.
I thousand percent. No, on, in a public
setting. I mean, obviously not at home,
but here's a simple workaround.
I mean,
it's just kind of grody to spit and
then wipe your ass with your own spit.
It's just, it's gross.
But I'm saying it's a,
if you're sitting in a public bathroom
where you don't have a sink near you,
you don't have a beverage with you.
Oh,
well here's what I'm telling you is that
bring in you've, you've mentioned this,
yeah. Bring the water bottle
in. Well, I'm, I'm saying,
I'm saying you don't have it.
Like you just didn't have it. Yeah.
And you're feeling dirty. No. Yeah.
You need something to clean
up, man. I'm 100% fine.
I would rather dry rub it a
thousand times, then spit.
It's just why I'm just opposed to spitting
and toilet paper and rubbing it on my
ass hole. I just, I would rather dry
rub it and you know, I, I so gross.
You can loosen some of that
dry mess up man with the,
with the spirit and on your own
spit it. I just, I don't know.
Sure if I've done it many times. I
didn't, I didn't, you know, nasty.
I started doing it a year or two ago
because your dad taught you though.
It was my, uh, uh,
brother-in-law one of the mentioned
that and I was like, oh, gross.
And then I was like, oh yeah, that
makes a lot of sense. Started doing it.
It's really so thankful for her
husband fucking, Hey Hitler's,
I just listened to four oh six decided
to pull him high and tight and drop a
note. I've been married to
my first cousin for 23 years.
We have three normal offspring with
all the normal bits and pieces.
I wouldn't date my mom, but I would
marry my mom's sister's daughter.
Just like the gays.
Before breeding,
we had all the testing done to make
sure we weren't going to have any tards.
All the families supported us.
I can't imagine sharing
my trip with anybody else.
Thanks for making an unbearable job.
Slightly less unbearable.
Mouth kisses all around. Jason, I told
you cousin fucking is. It's genetically.
No, it's no. That is incorrect.
Does that sound correct? You got to move
it to the, can I move it? It's going on.
It's just not working. Maybe it's a moving
because look, I'm out of frame again.
Isn't that weird? Oh my. Oh Em gee,
let's hop on lane. Not the, Oh,
it's trying to focus or it's,
it's, oh, oh my gosh. No,
I zoomed out right.
I think when we play clips,
it's trying to focus on this or something.
It's just not as,
oh my gosh.
Oh mg.
Sorry about that. Back to
cousin. Fucking completely wrong.
When you say it's okay.
He's telling me he has children
that are genetically fine.
You've got all the testing done because
like most people don't have to have all
the testing when before they
decided to start breeding. Sure.
So he's at a much higher risk for having
those genetic abnormalities and I would
say this guy is in the smallest
percentage of people who go,
we should do that before we reproduce
when they are first cousins. Okay.
It definitely causes abnormalities.
Oh yeah. I mean I don't know. I
don't know. I heard somewhere,
especially in relation to royal
marriages that they are married cousins
frequently in royal families,
like way back in the days they do.
What I'm saying is that,
but they don't have a lot of
tardies in in a the royal fam.
They have more genetic issues,
health problems than those who do not
reproduce within the same genetic family.
But it's not, it's not a for sure tar
towel. It's not for sure toward town,
but it's also not,
it's your higher probability for having
some type of health problems like dog
breeding. Of course. You
want to vary the genetic
pull. I, I clearly I understand that,
but I'm saying it's not necessarily a
tar town sentence. You're not necessarily
insulatard town.
And,
and what this guy had mentioned that they
had testing done beforehand I think is
probably really smart.
Yeah. It is smart, quick deal,
cousins look, call me, whatever.
I don't think marrying your
cousins that big of a deal.
I don't think it's that. I don't think
it's that sacrilege. The cousin, I didn't,
I don't have you think, I mean, I
wouldn't fuck my female cousins,
so I'm opposed to marrying and having
sex with any of my first cousins.
Um, like that one was
hot. Yeah. It doesn't,
it doesn't register on the thing
to me at all as a possibility,
but I know that it's also a very, very
common in a lot of cultures. So yes.
I'm just saying that I think,
I think more people should be
doing what he's doing and get,
I'm getting more tests again to make sure
it's our town isn't inevitable. Yeah.
Um, kick twins. Oh, sorry. I don't know
if you wanted to see this one. Okay. Yeah,
I was listening to
latest podcast with
no, she didn't say what that
Burp was so feeble. It was like,
why do it into the mic if you're
not even going to follow up?
It was week. I'll give you
the, oh, why would you do that?
I want to send some says a light on
this topic of identical twins having
identical penises.
I am a twin.
I can tell you that my brother and I
do in fact have different size penis on
vacation and my brother had too much to
drink and passed out on the couch in his
underwear.
My ex girlfriend who was on vacation
with us went into the living room and was
straight glass and at his apple bag
later on when I discussed it with her,
she described my brother's situation as
a large head shorter shaft hanging above
two coconuts.
However,
my setup is a normal head average
shaft and two regular size balls.
I hope this information helps you with
your debate next time and you're in,
you're in New York. Come by for
some moose soup. Sincerely, Mike,
Tom, and is the personality champs. Sorry.
No,
it's fine. Oh, it's already
happening. I don't know. It's the
camera or just wants to get close to me.
I'm so beautiful today, but this is crazy,
right? Yeah. We're not that blue band.
Fix it. Fucking hey man, wait. So
these twins are identical, correct?
Not, oh my OMG not fraternal. Right.
So they're dicks. Now here's my, my
question with this Dick Detection.
Dibs.
Go ahead.
Is,
uh,
he's talking about a flacid
drunk penis versus an erect,
you know, and I understand the, the
head of the penis, that's a big,
that is a difference and
aesthetic thing, you know? Yeah.
But I wonder if the size one when erect.
Well, this guy, um, we did, he didn't,
he said they don't have, you know,
when the question being at the
twins have identical penises,
he didn't say whether they were
fraternal or identical twins.
See, that's what I need. I need
identical twins. And I'm, I'm looking at,
cause I asked, I asked fraternal
twin Ryan sickler different penises.
Okay. He's a twin. [inaudible] different,
but we haven't asked identical twins yet.
I really love the scientific leanings.
Our show is taken lately.
I know it's pretty crazy,
right? How to blind people. Why
it's really, we're really
doing a lot of great work, man.
I don't know a lot of great work.
Um,
wait, can I share with you my
thought? Of course. So I, I, uh,
I found Chaz Bono on Twitter the other
day and I was looking at his whatever
feed and I noticed that like,
he's fully transitioned now.
I think he has a penis. Like he's fully,
fully, he's on board and he's on the team.
Yeah. I gotta tell Ya. And I mean
this, I'm not being a shithead. Yeah.
I think he's fucking hot,
really. I, you know what I mean?
Where did you see this image?
Just Google, Google image.
Chaz Bono 2017. Okay. Wait, is
it cha cha's that's his name now.
And I gotta tell you that, uh, you
know me, I like bears are like, um,
I like to big guys stocky and he looks,
I think he's hot. I think he did a
great job. Whoever did whatever work,
he looks great. Him. Yeah, he looks great.
I know. I like, no, that's too, I like
him with facial hair. Yeah. See there.
He's cute. Yeah. Well he's got
a good face. Looks good man.
And a lot of times when women see this,
like he's cute.
When women transition,
they don't always look masculine
enough. Yeah. But he's lucky.
I think the weight actually makes him
look more. Oh, I like that picture.
That was cute. Yeah. See he's cute.
Yeah. It looks like a regular dude. Yeah,
it looks really good.
It's just face is really good for a man.
This transition is like quite impressive
action. Oh my gosh. I mean, you know,
they're always like, you're always, or
at least, you know, generally speaking,
um, it's usually about women. They're
like, that looks like, oh my God,
she can fool you, right? Yeah. Yeah.
You don't really see that as much with
the other way. Like when a woman training,
that's what I'm saying.
It's so hard for us to get
bulkier to get to look masculine,
but his features are really,
really,
yeah. There's no way if you ran
into this dude, you'd be like, Hey,
were you a woman before?
You would never think.
And the weight helps, I
think. Yeah. Fela Mau and,
oh see there's a picture
of him with his shirt off,
like sitting in shorts and
stuff. Yeah. It looks great.
Or that you would never know
that that was a woman dude.
He looks fantastic than it used
to be. A woman. Sorry. Yes. Yeah.
That's what that he was a woman before.
I mean, yeah, it looks great. It's true.
True. So anyway, I just had
already changed. I don't
understand what's going on.
Know what's happened.
Okay. Um, I gotta tell you this because
normally we don't do this. Okay.
Normally when, when we have, um,
like a sh a shirt launch, uh,
we've had a few in recent weeks,
completely normal came back to Netflix.
So we did,
we re leased a new version of sub cane
as like a celebration where I partnered
with dos Brac, I think, I don't know
how to say his name right on, um, on,
on Instagram. He's a
great artist. And then I,
we did Moose suit cause it was so timely,
but then we got this unbelievable
submission for a shirt design.
And I have to uh,
make sure I,
I say correctly the credit for it.
So this shirt design was so
funny that I was like, yeah, we,
we absolutely have to, to
do that. And the guy's name,
here we go is a Mark Glass.
So He's, he's totally glass and
mark last, um, he has, let's see,
designed by humans.com he did rob,
rob,
rob, the rub, rub, rub shirt.
I've seen,
I laughed so hard at this
design that I was like,
we were just going to put it up.
So it's up there.
If you go to merchant method.com
are you serious? We made this shirt.
Yeah. Immediately. Oh my God. Yeah.
And how would you describe it? I'd
prefer not to come on. No, you go ahead.
Well, it says, it says,
of course, the great
phrase. I'm rob, Rob, Rob, Rob, rob, rob,
and then as my face and it looks like
my eyes are struggling to stay open
because I'm in ecstasy. And, uh,
it looks like something
is dripping off of,
of the face there. Yeah, that's good.
Hey, it's your call. I mean
if you want the shirt around,
of course I wandered around. Come dripping
from your beard. Be My guess babe.
That's what it is. More appreciative.
I am. I think it's really neat.
Thank you mark.
Thanks mark. I just wanted to give you
a shout out to the size of our sun,
babe.
You got a kid wants to wear that
rob. Rob, can I tell you
something else had happened? Um,
we actually had the rub rub
guy cut together with Kim in
great [inaudible] man
for a little audio fun.
Do you want to hear what the two of them?
Something like that.
Uh, Kim Man, of course if you don't
know is uh, one of the great um,
performers of all time
and she and the Rub Rub guy,
uh,
are both Asian and we decided
they're both sexual people.
What would happen if we threw
them together whenever we do what?
Go ahead. I was going to say
that we've been working on that.
Blue bands been working on this,
cause we had the idea a few weeks ago,
you and I were sitting
down and we thought,
wouldn't it be a power couple if you will?
The two of them,
two of them are perfect. Yeah.
Yeah. Two, two of the great.
This is like what it would be like if
the two of them met and did some work
together. It's a blue
band. Put this together.
We do the scene.
Always fuck
hard on way ancient sex.
And you get the oil in the head
and Europe, ruff, ruff, ruff,
ruff.
And what you need to do is
be mindful about your spine,
especially in the vagina,
especially on the wrap them.
You need to stop judgment
from right or wrong.
The time, once, one side,
50 times left side phone,
50 time that people come down.
This cop,
my tight Asian Pussy.
Mm,
there you go. That was beautiful. It
was really good. Better than I expected.
So that's a great man.
Waiting for that
really special. What's his
name? Um, I looked it up. It's,
uh, it's not Kyle. I'll tell
you that. It's different.
I forgot. I forgot. I don't want to
look it up again, but it's, it's,
it's a good name, special name. Um, then,
uh, somebody put this, this
is you. I guess this is,
you
could press pause right now.
I want to take care of something for that
little jeans. Okay. I'll be right back.
All right, hold on. Turn up
the thermostat. Um, yeah.
So you did that.
I change the setting on this.
I don't know who does autos. Zoom.
Why that's even an option. Hey,
could you set this thing to
zoom whenever it feels like it,
it was this video of you,
um,
I guess you did this while you
were driving or something. Okay.
I see.
At the end of the day,
I'm still going to go home to my
Nigga fuck him and get my pussy ate.
Wow. Wow. Big words. Hmm. That's, um,
if you're just listening as
most of the audience does,
that's a white lady who was
real comfortable throwing
things around. That's,
those are big words.
Real big.
Oh,
fuck bitch.
Why would you tell somebody
you don't know this?
Real sad and obviously you pissy,
I'm not ugly bitch in my head go down
in her defense and I hear
is just a theory. Uh,
she could be a mixed, you know what
I mean? Like she could be okay.
I'm just trying,
I'm just trying to help her out.
Yeah.
There are black people that are really
super light. Oh No, you're totally right.
100% right. She's not,
yeah. Well Hey. Yeah.
But I mean she's putting it out
there and Caribbean, you know,
she's got those nice eyes. Pretty eyes
like Rihanna is kind of light skinned.
Yeah. This is, this is quite a few shades
lighter. Okay. This is, uh, I dunno.
I would say she's Kinda like me. Well, no,
she's not like a blonde blue. I
know, I know, but I'll just stop
Sanjay and I don't see nasty bitch ass.
I forgot her name. You ever heard of
it anyway, but I still can't find you.
I'm way know everybody that was talking
shit to comment. The black bitches,
white bitches. Niggas don't
know them. I'm still waiting.
No. Where do you think, uh, what do you
think she's from? South Atlanta. Yeah,
it's the south, but now is
Atlanta, not the deep south.
We're talking like Atlanta south.
What'd he call? Okay. What I'm saying?
Cause like when you're Alabama's
different accent than like Atlanta.
That's what I'm saying. Are you thinking
from Bama or something negative?
I'm saying she's from Atlanta.
Oh,
see I think she's from a
smaller populated area. Oh.
My guess would be that she's maybe,
maybe she's in the outskirts of like
Norfolk or something. Yeah. Okay.
Oh Hey, that's another one. Yeah.
Yeah, because Virginia is super weird.
Yeah. That's a real
weird next. Yeah. Yeah.
But like she doesn't live in Norfolk
like she lives trysting theory 30 minutes
from it and yeah.
You know,
there's some country has shit
going on where she lives for sure.
Now she's responding to the haters
in her comment feed. Is that,
I think she must have like
posted something. I mean,
I'm sure there's a more,
this girl was upset on Facebook.
She's not afraid to use big words and
all we got on it, but interesting. Yeah.
I don't care what race you are, Babe.
I'm not racist. Bitch got me fucked up.
But it's just the back bitches that's out.
So that's why I said black bitches.
Is She driving? Yeah. I always
wonder how people do that. Yeah.
Cause I think to get out that much
anger while you're driving is not even,
it's not good for your driving.
I wish you would pull over.
Yeah.
I think it's weird.
Maybe it's different to brag about how
good you are at writing Dick. Well,
you know, as Margaret Thatcher said, if
you have to tell people you're a lady,
right.
It's the talkers that Eh,
it's always the quiet
ones that are doing shit.
You got to top dog face
while I'm thinking about how,
I bet she's just really aggressive.
Like I could,
I could see her busting like
breaking. You're Dong Open. Yeah.
I think she probably miss mistakes
and through Z. Asm for good.
For good. Yeah. There's a lot
of enthusiasm there. A lot
of anger, energy, you know,
it's not the same negative.
It's not the same as as doing good.
You guys are doing good. Yeah.
It's different in iron. Okay,
motherfucker
ain't got no career then
now I'm taking care of Yaki.
Well we should put the phone down.
Nigga would say Nigga too.
I Dunno. I think there's some people, you
know what I'm curious of. Go ahead. Um,
how many,
uh,
black people would prefer somebody
to be this open with their big words?
Right. You know what I mean?
Like I remember one time, um,
it was a Clayton Peter's Russell Peters
brother told me when he had a corporate
job, he worked with a guy that he
knew was racist, but the guy, he goes,
he was open about it and that's what I
respected about him, that he liked ladies.
I do think she's probably right
and that she's probably not racist.
I definitely don't think she actually,
I think she's somebody who
thinks that she has a hall pass.
She thinks she has a hall pass because
she's got black inner meaning it black by
injection. So she's thinking like,
well do to have sex with a black guy.
Like I clearly am down. Most of her
friends are probably below culturally,
you know, she does obviously
spend time in that community.
There's a certain level of
comfortability with that.
I wonder if like if most people are cool,
I think she's cool or,
or if people are like, no, I
don't prefer that you do this.
I don't know. I can only speculate, but I,
I can't imagine that anybody would be
like, that's okay. You can say that.
I think some people would. Yeah,
it wouldn't be a boy. I know.
That's what I'm talking about.
It's not a blanket vote.
I think it wouldn't be 100% I just wonder
if it's 90% or whether it's more 50 50
that's what you're taking.
Unofficial poll. Yeah, sure.
I would love to take on official bowl.
If you're black and you're listening to
this and post on the Facebook page or
send an email to your mom's
podcast@gmail.com it's not
your mom's house podcast.
It's your mom's podcast and let us
know if you go, actually, I don't mind.
The thing is,
this is fine.
As long as you're hanging out with a
lot of black people having sex with him,
I guess it's okay. Well she, I mean,
I'm sure the guys that have sexual
her all the time, we're probably like,
this is fine. That's me. That's
point of view. All right.
Anybody that would willing to,
like if you were like,
I'm going to call you names or whatever,
I'd be like, okay, well here's the,
here's a story. So you know,
I talk about this in my,
my hour that's going to come out soon
as having an Indian stuff family.
I had an Indian Stepdad and
three Indian step sisters.
We were very politically incorrect
round the house. Oh. It was a joke.
Like we'd call him, my mother would
call him a towel head and why don't you,
why don't you put fucking
laundry on your head?
And then he would call her Goulash
tits or whatever lake and there's,
it was just silliness. But
see, like that's, you know,
that's still different from this though,
because that to me is affection.
Like all my friends that are of any
marginalized group or ethnic group that
aren't white. I, if I really care
for it, if I really liked him,
I would tease them. I have my whole
life. Yeah. About whatever it is.
Right? Yeah. But that to me is like
you're showing that's like a way,
a sign of affection for gun.
Well,
it's also an old school way of showing
affection. Like this is different.
Like was so, so loaded. It's
such a, it's such a harsh,
I mean like to,
I have black friends that I say,
um, you know, inappropriate things too,
but I don't drop and bombs on them.
Um, I have a, I mean,
you know, like Ari, I,
I would buy would feel weird not saying
something to you about his Jewish. Yeah.
But that's like, because I like if I
didn't like him, I would never say, okay,
so let's, well, let's do this conversation
because I did have an word in my act,
uh, prior, not that I'm saying
it, I say as Dick Clark,
assuming that he was a racist
piece of shit. So now I did that.
I've done that bit in front of Black
Comedians for a while now and I've gotten
an,
you know,
and people that were pretty close with
and I've never gotten anything negative
feedback and they'll fucking tell you.
I feel like I'm close enough
to people that they'll be like,
that's really fucked up.
Anyway, I guess it's context,
dude contract.
It's an interesting,
it's an interesting cultural debates is
more like the Rachel Dole is all thing.
She's where she's like,
I can say whatever I want.
Not that that's wrong because that
lady didn't say that. That I'm,
what I'm saying is that, that
that lady was like, I'm black.
She's clearly a white lady. She's
like, yeah, but I identify as black,
which is crazy.
But I think that this,
this person right now basically thinks,
I mean without saying it,
I think she thinks that she's in the club.
It's called cultural appropriation
happening a lot here. Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
No,
no bitch.
Bitch thinks she can beat my ass.
I will wait on it cause I would stay if
they Nigga to anybody. That's up to me.
Whether you white, black, Mexican,
he don't care. I don't care. Black,
white,
Chinese or candy.
Stripe. I don't give a fuck.
Yeah. I don't know man.
She has that thing where she goes,
I don't care.
Rick Ross,
my mom and Laura, my
sister, my sister does.
Sweet southern. Yeah. She's
Super Sad. Yeah, it does
get spoke. Her name. Monica hot. You
want to look up? Yeah, it sounds good.
I know bitch trying to play me. I
don't care. What color do we use?
Yeah. Yeah. Different strokes. Same,
same strokes for everybody. Yeah,
that's fine. Cause I white bitch
spoke up to Galle is cheese.
Yeah.
I never had a child but that's
why boot you found the right one.
She's really, I mean if she's
auditioning and she's got the part, yeah,
I'd be like, yeah, your dad, you did it
right. Did that. He definitely got it.
Well she feels,
I mean that's the question too with
Rachel Doughlas all in with this kind of,
with this girl. It's like what does it
mean? Like, if you feel a certain culture,
you know,
you feel like that's your culture and
you're raised in that environment.
Like who's to say, you know, I don't
fucking know. I don't know. I don't know.
I feel like she's bought a lot of guys
sneakers at the mall for them before,
but I dunno. Is that all it takes
to win a man's heart? I mean,
so snakes, I think she's,
she knows exactly. He's like
everyone's one 13. Yeah,
I got you. I got you. Okay. I
got you. I think I do blue, blue.
Wow. Yeah, she's um, she's
something I'm trying to think of.
Well, yeah, I dunno dude, whatever.
Thank [inaudible] everybody.
I'm going to ball Sacramento,
California punchline.
I think the, uh, the two
early shows are sold out.
I think there might be tickets left to
the late show August 12th and maybe,
maybe August 11th to,
um, check it out. Tom.
skirt.com/tour Thompson grow.com/tour.
And what else? Uh, if you go to my,
that same page I am hearing up to shoot
a special September 6th in Denver.
They released an extra couple of hundred
tickets that were withheld because of
the shooting. So the early show has
less than a hundred tickets left.
That's September 16th late
show has maybe a few more,
but they're going to be gone sooner.
If you want to go to the taping,
it's in Denver. I'm also doing
Oakland, Lincoln, Nebraska.
I'm doing a Springfield,
Missouri, Midwest City,
Oklahoma, and I'm going to
Toronto, Portland, Maine,
couple other that have
been added in recent, uh,
weeks coming to do a big show here
in la at the Wiltern in November. Um,
so there's a bunch of shows. Check
out to see if your city is on my site.
Thompson [inaudible] dot
com slash tour gene. Uh,
I know you have a couple coming up,
right? I do. Yes. First
of all, August 23rd,
we're doing your mom's house alive
and breast balls, beach at the Improv.
So con Florida,
Florida.
If you're in Palm Beach County,
Broward County, Indian River County,
Dade County, please come
out to the breasts, balls,
beach Improv,
Jay County
also,
September 22nd and 23rd.
I'm in Saint Jude tits
or Saint Louis tits.
Missoura helium,
comedy crab,
October 4th in Charlotte, North
Cack, Alaska, the comedy zone.
October 5th, Nashville,
Tennessee, uh, at the xannies.
And then October 8th, we're
doing your mom's house live
in sperm, vine, California.
And we were honoring the tickets from
July 9th since we had to push that.
So apologies. But we will be honoring
your tickets there. October 8th.
Also. Check out. That's deep. Well, uh,
I answer people's crazy life emails.
It'd be like talking about life and
getting deep on stuff. Check out that
Bro.
And that's it man.
Thanks Ross. Dude, this is blood Danza
last week I talk about Bukowski's.
Don't try,
if you ever heard of that
on his tombstone is written.
Don't try to talk about that quote,
man. Isn't that the funniest thing ever?
I really, it's very meaningful. So
I get deep on that. That's great.
I really liked that. Hmm. Hmm.
Hmm. Oh, okay.
Okay.
Fucking
she gas it. Fucking sheep.
He's fired up though. Ah, speaking of UK.
So last week we were
talking about why on earth,
why on earth would a man choose to be a
gynecologist and how it was interesting
fucking weird.
That is.
And you've clearly got to be a pervert
of some sort and women, uh, Dick Doctors.
Yeah. Well I can't, we
can't speak on that, but,
so this gent gentlemen
in from the UK and um,
okay, so he says he works with a
number of male consultant gynecologist.
They vastly outweigh the women,
which is definitely an unusual seeing
as medical school is roughly 60,
40 women to men. So anyways,
he thinks the big attraction,
why men choose gynecology. Uh, he writes,
you're able to separate
yourself from what you see.
So although the issue around
sex is definitely there,
that is a relatively small price to pay
to know that nothing you see can happen
to you. And also not having a frame of
reference on how it would actually feel,
which is good. So meaning if it's
a total train wreck down there,
you can look at it impartially
as an outsider and go,
well I guess I'd better stitch this back
on and get on with it instead of like,
if you're looking at a dick, it's like
cut. You're, you're too empathetic almost.
Yeah. Interesting. So it's
actually, if you're full of empathy,
it's great to remove yourself from your
sec. Totally. And that makes sense.
Like you don't want,
you want a divorce completely.
I never thought of that either.
And secondly, he says that the, um,
it's a real macho field,
gynecology and doing
gynecological procedures and
surgeries and it's very macho
and Hari is also much easier to track
than that. I don't remember. I don't know.
I can't think it was in the email that
it's easier to get into gynecology. Yeah,
I dunno then then if you were to be
like a fucking heart surgeon. Oh, right.
But the, but the glamor is high.
So meaning like there's, uh, it's,
it's just more prestigious
to do, I guess, you know,
women's stuff really. It's
difficult. Yeah. Yeah.
He says it's very macho
cause you're, you're really,
you're playing God, you know,
with women's innards and big
fibroids and shit like that.
Like his wife comes out.
Yeah.
So it's a high reward and guessing.
Anyways, I thought that was fascinating.
That is, that's interesting. Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Still yelling at a sheep.
Fucking hell.
Mine
fucking move. Yeah. Five days.
So mad at an innocent cheap.
Can you do his accent?
A fucking movie.
That's pretty good.
You're fucking shit. You're fucked.
And it's Scotland Scottish. He's,
he calls him a fat Dick. Fat Dick.
Yeah, that's what he said there
all your content.
Fucking hell.
Mine Cuna El Mundo
can move. Yeah, no, it sounds like
all right.
Francis Begbie train spot.
I watched the second one you did on the
flight. Did you love it? That was great,
dude. I fucking love that movie.
I mean, it can't live up to par.
It's like when it, I think when
the movie really moves into the,
whatever, the third act, I
was not as invested in it.
It's kind of like, Oh, this
is movie making. This is, uh,
making this story come together. But it's
fun to see the characters again. Yes.
That's the part. I enjoy
it, Sandra. Then. Yeah,
seeing them back and getting
in trouble was cool. Yeah,
it was fun. It's cool. It's,
it's a fucking great movie. Trainspotting
dude. Fuck deck. Yeah. If Fat Dick,
that
cupid cut.
Fuck Shit.
Fucking hell fucking hey,
fuck off.
I'm just glad I didn't hurt the sheep.
I was scared when I first saw he doesn't,
I mean,
he just drives away,
but he's just angry as shit that
he can't drive down the street.
I kind of don't like when they spray paint
sheep. I feel like it's really silly.
Don't spray paint. Nice wool. Yeah.
He's, he's very, this guy's real aggro.
Yep. Yeah. I enjoyed him though. I
fucking code. Yeah, he's a lot.
He's got a lot of things. That's
what oil middle road.
Oh my God.
So of course there's no such thing.
Nothing can compare to the,
the greatest dad Boehner of all time.
Oh yeah.
We know who that is.
Canada highway. It's the Canadian
Dad boner for the Canadian. He,
he definitely wears the crown.
Oh,
the story that this road towels.
Nobody. Oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh. See now,
and I'm listening to him.
Does he, is he joking?
He just loves highways.
So we've had different
ones. We've had, you know,
dad boners that love whatever it
is. Solar eclipse, the trains,
right train boners are pretty big.
This is our first plane boner.
This guy parks in a fast food parking lot
and watch his planes on their approach
at an airport and I'm willing and gets
really fucking excited about it. I mean,
it's, he, he's in the running. I
mean, he can't eclipse Canadian Dad,
but this is pretty excitable
for fucking commercial airlines.
Oh, it's not like special,
no planes landing.
It's like Sesnas and
shit. No. Hmm. Oh yeah.
That's an Airbus three one nine
there's one, three, three,
yeah. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh,
Boeing seven 37
it's like a southwest plane, Bro. Relax
this guy. Is this excited for this? Oh,
my word. Oh my word. Oh my word. I'm 37 so
you notice that also,
by the way,
that these guys are all these dad boners
are real clean. Like they don't curse.
Yeah, that's it. Oh my word. Oh
my God. Heavens and stars. Yeah.
Cheese and rice. They don't go fucking
Bowleys shit. Yeah, yeah. That's true.
Train guy too. He was
like, Oh, this is, oh no.
I think it's because you're sublimating
everything else in your life for that.
Like you're repressing something
else somewhere else maturing.
You're not allowing your brain to mature.
You're not using your Dick. You're not.
You're not having come gazumped. What if
the guy took you on a day and he goes,
we're going to park at this white castle.
Oh, watch planes, land and feeling.
Are we five?
Ours are a little toddler likes playing.
He loves a point up with them by, by
the waves. The waves. Bye Bye to them.
Are you one and a half? Yeah. That's kind
of what this guy should be doing. Yeah.
His, his development is stunted
somewhere. Right? It's not normal.
These are not commercial.
Okay. These are planes there.
Thousands of them land every day.
Every year. If you've ever flown, yeah.
You're like, okay, that's sucked. Unless
he's putting it on like putting us all on,
you know, these are just
giant fart bubbles in the sky.
It's like they're so gross thing.
Exciting about this.
No, I can't believe it. A Boeing
seven 37 come from Los Angeles.
Maybe he's touched. Yeah, he might
be special. He could be very special.
Wait, we haven't even thought
of that. What if he's just
tarted? He's not retarded.
I you sure he parked?
No,
no. Someone drove him there. No,
I don't think. I don't think so.
I think he's retarded.
I don't think he's retarded that.
I think that he's just really,
it's just misguided energy.
You know?
It's like you shouldn't be like this. No,
you should have orgasms. It's done. Yeah.
You should feel like just for
like tits. Right? Right. What if,
but what if they are on the spectrum
of some kind of behavioral? I guess so.
I guess that's possible. It's do.
It's weird though, for sure. Super.
We're saying we could see there
now. It could be that this guy's doing
a bit. No, no, no. The genuine. Yeah.
That's real. Enthusiasm is too
real. Coming from Los Angeles.
That's like, he's so stoked.
That's how little kids are.
How did you know that was from la?
See it? What about the following?
The flight patterns? I mean there's
like apps, like flight deck.
You can see what time?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Come on.
It's a fun character to play it.
Yeah. Oh, Boeing seven three seven
Oh my word so far. And to
deferred. Did it pick it up?
Maybe subtly. Yes. So exciting.
It's not exciting to me. Now
I remember why it's not. Oh,
it doesn't smell very good. Oh God.
Yeah. I'm still in it. It's my own hello.
Help mommies. In the last few years I've
killed a relationship with my own mom.
She wasn't in my life for years
because of addiction and other factors.
As we have hung out more often, things
are back to normal and we part ways.
She tries to plan a smooch
right on my mouth. Personally,
I wouldn't marry my mom and try
to turn a cheek before it lands.
What's the best way to duck out of these
mouth kisses with my mom without being
a, how you say asshole Tim. Oh wait,
okay, so you're a dude and she's your
mom. Yeah. And they put, they had,
you know, many years apart.
Things are better now,
but she tries to do mouth kisses.
Cause I tell you,
there's somebody in my life who con and
for years it goes to say goodbye to me
and mount and tries to mouth kiss.
What you do is go for the cheek.
You just bypass the mouth and go
cheek and the act like that's that.
That's what you was just establish.
You just establish that.
I think you could start, you could start
leading kisses. That's maybe the way,
in other words, when you say
hello, give her a hug and like,
just go right. Go right for
that cheek. You know? So it's,
it's not really, you're not
responding. You're not playing defense.
You're being playing offense.
That's what I do with this.
That's a good way to do it. Yeah. Who does
that? I'll tell you off Mike. All right.
It's a friend that I've had for,
you know, 17 years. Oh really?
God,
it's weird.
I know how blind people know
when they're done wiping mommy's.
I can't believe no one has
written the real answer. People,
black people full the teepee when
they think they are done. If the,
this is a fucking goof, I
don't know. This is nothing.
Sorry guys. Um, how many
head scratches equal one Bj?
Boy, my boyfriend and I had been listening
to the podcast since we started dating
four years ago.
We recently bet on John Jones versus
Daniel Cormier fight number two.
If Jon Jones wins,
I get five head scratches.
If DC wins, my boyfriend gets one. Bj,
we were wondering if this is the proper
exchange rate for head scratch. BJ's.
Well, first of all, Justine,
thanks Hitler's. She writes.
Justine, first of all,
congratulations on your head.
Scratchies because Jon Jones did
indeed win this past weekend.
Five head scratchers for one. Bj. Yeah.
Now that sounds about right.
That sounds right to you. Well,
it depends because I would say you
owe me dozens of Bj's at this point,
I think. But here's the thing, the
head scratches for me has to be,
I go to sleep with them.
So you need to do the scratchies
until I'm asleep more than you think.
That's five that I give you five.
Well,
how many is that? You probably
get 40 to 60 oh no, no,
she's saying five. I'm sorry,
I understood this to mean five,
five sessions of Scott show.
I think you need to be clear about that
and a lot of people are like, you know,
one, two, three, four, five
scratches. That's bullshit.
That's not even a head scratch.
You're saying do five hedge
scratchy sessions equal a Bj?
I think that's about right.
If it's a session five sessions full,
which means we're laying in bed,
I'm ready to go to sleep and then I go
give me scratchies and then I get the
scratches until I fall asleep.
Yeah.
I've been trying to ask for the
Bj in return for those scratches,
but we're just marking
up your debt by the way.
You totally just blew
off your helicopter Bj's.
Those are supposed to be an agreed upon.
We've gotten distracted. Life took over.
We didn't get back to the discussion.
If you don't want to see
me in a by by pretty soon,
but by better start I've had my eye on
so how much dog food will I need to eat
for that man? No, I'm serious.
I want a new updated wedding ring
because ours was so, I can't wear it.
I'm allergic.
But how many cans of dog food will I
have to eat for a new wedding band?
We can we switch it up?
Why don't we switch it up to Bj's and
dog food or just don't have any more dog
food. Okay. Yeah. I felt bad when you ate
that last time. It was worth it though.
This rings are all nice.
It's a nice ring to waste.
The other one now it's this
one. Oh yeah, that's right.
That's the food ring. This you gave me for
my special, which is very sweet of you.
Yeah,
I do need a proper wedding band cause the
other one I can't wear skin breaks out.
We've talked about this. You're supposed
to give me some things to take in
and I got this.
These balls are all full.
I need those kind of
just got home last night.
You came home all tired
and you took shifts.
Remember last night we were going to
sleep and you're like, I'll go to shit.
And I'm like, thanks. You've
been shitting since you got home.
We haven't had a chance to get
in there. Hey Mommy, I'm an AIDS.
Lana Mommy right into needs.
Lana about people facetiming. Ah,
I'm currently getting my car worked on.
I'm in the lobby and these low end loose
assholes or facetiming with someone
singing happy birthday twice. Stop
once in Spanish. Once an English,
Jesus Christ Christo.
After they finished singing,
they continue to have their conversation
with the person with the vault all the
way up to over 15 minutes. I go outside,
but it's nine degrees and humid.
This is a low and loose situation. Stay
high and tight. Caesar or [inaudible].
I don't know how you say it,
but that is some fucking bullshit.
I really feel like we, you know,
it's time to start telling people,
hey, are you fucking out
of your mind right now?
Where were we when that old guy's
phone went off? And I was like,
did I say something to him?
I was like, oh, no, no, no.
Hell No. Hell No. I didn't.
I say that to him. I don't
remember. I remember that I, dude,
I bet it was just ringing
and ringing and ringing.
Then that's the worst one.
All people swarming,
and I don't even fucking pick it up.
I was in a doctor's office where a
patient had words with another patient,
which doctor Dix off. No,
no, no different doctor.
The witch doctory just don't worry about
it. I'm just kidding. So the person,
the person was the phone and it
says there's a big sign there,
no cell phones allowed. And so another
patient in the doctor's office goes,
excuse me, good. And that person on the
phone was like, like, what? She's like,
you're not supposed to be on your phone
in here. And she was like, oh. She's like,
um, I, and she was like, I
got to go. Someone's saying,
and it's like, well, yeah,
but there's a huge sign that says it.
No one wants to hear your
fucking conversation.
That's the worst part about this is
that it's really an intrusion on other
people's audit. That's the whole
issue. Yeah. And you don't even,
you don't even fucking think about it.
Like that's the thing.
There's people who just don't, they
don't think about it. That to me,
an auditory assault me, it
makes me, I hate Whistler's.
I had people that talk on their fucking
speaker phone or watch a movie full
volume, why we're married. These
are like, these are actually,
these are core values or core values.
The tenants of our marriage
or really that were like,
don't abuse my ears in public.
Well,
you and I are not yellers and
we never yell across the house.
That's fucking not happening. No. Yeah.
And we don't like loud sounds or public.
Yeah. Stop being so fucking loud, man.
Yeah. Why are you so fucking loud? Yeah.
Very rude. It's super rude. It's
just obliviousness, you know.
Hey Jane. Hi Jeans with G. N.
E. S. It's a new one. Yeah.
You've talked about workers coming over
and taking a shit in your house. Yup. Yup,
Yup.
My mom has people working on her roof
who came over and immediately dropped hot
sevens in her bathroom. She called
me at the end of the day. I say,
told me that not only was there a
worker brown sprayed all over the toe,
but that her dog went in the trash and
shredded toilet paper all over the house.
She cleaned it up.
She realized there was Brown on the paper.
These workers shit in her house and
through the poo paper in the trashcan.
Oh dear. What the fuck? I
guess it's just like the gays.
I know a few people that aren't going
to be invited over for moose soup.
No questions here.
Just sharing.
One of the worst things I've
ever heard of happening. Well,
there's a good chance that those are
from Latin America. Those guys, you know,
so they are used to throw
in their poop paper in the,
in the trash because of the plumbing
down there or it could be they're working
on the plumbing.
Maybe she didn't say what type of workers
they are and maybe the plumbing roof.
She said, no, I bet it's that. Because my,
one of my buddies who's married to
a Mexican woman said that, you know,
when the family visited, he was
like, I had to keep, I'm like,
do not put your shit paper in the toilet.
And they,
and they don't put it in the trash.
Yeah.
To a habit. So he puts signs in the
bathroom. Good. Yeah. Flesh side.
We flush it down, dude. If it's brown,
it goes down. All of it. All of it.
Anything Brown. Even if you have a
brown shirt on, he put it in the toilet.
You flush it away. Americans do not.
We don't want to see it. Smell it.
Just go away. Yeah. It goes go August.
Horrifying to a god that Nancy,
it's such a weird,
oh,
she's so weird about it.
I would've crashed my car if I was at
that red light and that lady on a moped
was like, I gotta go, Ah, ah. I like that.
She drives away like this.
You need to go back.
Yeah,
it is.
Okay.
Go.
She goes, oh my God. Yeah.
Where do you think is this Texas? I
bet you this is Texas. No White Lexus.
Cause I like the see the strip malls.
Yeah.
It's in my mind those ladies
are so nice to her though.
The ladies and the other car,
I think that they were enjoying it
and using the cover of being nice,
which is a good way you need to go to
the hospital because if I were laughing I
would be like, y'all write too,
but then just keep laughing. Yeah.
That's fucking funny. Funny. But a psycho.
I know. God, the world is so messed up.
Um, what else? I'm supposed to be on
Conan next week. Oh, okay. Always.
I say supposed to because you never
know how things change and yeah.
So showbiz guys. Yeah, but
maybe keep an eye out for that.
I'm gonna make some moose soup.
I am. Anything else for Eugene's?
Um, I mean not, you know, no. Same
Shit. Different toilet guys. Same Shit.
Different toilet.
Oh,
that's cute. Yup. So yeah,
little face I'll put in face of putting
pop kid. Who is that? That is, uh,
my son keeping it hot. Devin from shits
field acid. [inaudible] s a two shifts.
It's very cute. Good title. Good.
Good job. Good job buddies. All right.
That's it gene. Um, that's it.
Anything else? Let me just make sure.
Yeah. Okay. Thanks for
listening to the show.
Thanks for supporting the show.
Uh,
we'll be back next week and
that's it. All right, Jean,
I love you guys. Sorry for the zooming
in and out in the first part of the show,
but I don't mean annoying.
Uh,
this is a state troopers by Chris
Spence as your closing song.
Hello. Alright. Couple of state
Gruber's God bless everybody. Bye. Jane,
do you think you could spend
like a few hours just farming?
Well,
I mean
the Sun would kiss the dad's mouth
mother with kids. The son's mouth.
They don't make bullet astro when we
talking about couple of state troopers.
Okay. Yeah. Dude, you just like farts.
I got to keep my teeth
together. Yeah. Okay.
He is placing all of his
eggs in the spark basket.
I'm about to talk about the guy,
right? The Guy, the guy, right? Yeah.
Do you feel the tongue come into
your mouth? God, your breath,
which is do,
I don't want to get into the detail
level,
what I mean like,
well, I mean, look, wow.
I mean like, well, I mean,
look, come to your mouth. I mean,
like we talking about
date do burst. Yeah. Okay.